Sí y ya de hecho la Casa Blanca se
refirió al respecto el portavoz de la
Casa Blanca uno de ellos dijo que siguen
muy de cerca los movimientos que se van
a dar tanto en Washington como en Nueva
York de Cara a la llegada del
expresidente Trump a el aeropuerto la
guardia el expresidente Trump viaja en
su avión privado de Nueva York que se
quedará esta noche en su apartamento
privado y mañana después del mediodía
pues irá a se presentará a las
autoridades donde le leerán los cargos
sé que se calcula que son cerca de 30 o
más de 30 cargos a los que se le acusa
formalmente este gran Jurado a el
expresidente Donald Trump la
manifestación en Nueva York al frente
precisamente de la de la corte donde se
le dan los cargos ser está convocada a
las doce del mediodía hora de Estados
Unidos hora local o la del este Estados
Unidos y después de esto Pues será esta
lectura de cargos a esta manifestación
pues eh va a haber mucha mucho
despliegue de la fuerza pública Además
porque se espera que vaya la congresista
mayo y Taylor Green una congresista del
estado de Georgia que entre otros apoya
la teoría de Conspiración de quanón
estará ya presente y sin duda Pues será
un evento bastante mediático Cristóbal
ahora cómo ha afectado este proceso
legal la imagen de Trump
pues de hecho los asesores de Trump le
han advertido con mucho detalle y le han
insistido que por favor
guarde sus límites esto después de que
precisamente Hace unas horas el ex
presidente haya tenido que bajar de su
red social
una foto en la que aparecía él con un
bate de béisbol tratando como en
dirección como si le fuera a pegar al
juez Alvin que es el juez que lo acusa
de que le acusa y que del cual se
conocerán los cargos en las próximas
horas mañana después del mediodía
precisamente de haber usado plata de
campaña para financiar esta este
silencio esta actriz porno entonces
horas después de haber publicado este
este esta este trino o este esta
publicación en su red social los
asesores le dijeron que por favor lo
quitara le insistieron él lo quitó y lo
que le están diciendo es que vaya con
mucha calma porque cualquier paso en
falso del expresidente Donald Trump le
podría costar mucho en su campaña de
hecho hoy mismo uno de los precandidatos
republicanos gobernador del estado de
Washington dijo que no quería y que no
era y que no era oportuno para el
partido republicano que el Donald Trump
se presentara como candidato
Precisamente en medio de estas
acusaciones recordemos que Donald Trump
no solamente es el primer presidente en
ser acusado formalmente por un gran
Jurado sino que tiene detrás Dos
procesos de